hello theo hello brendan i gotta say
the two of you guys are the greatest duo
since martin and lewis
you're far superior to millie vanilli or
shields and yarnell
you might need to look them up today's
debate club question is quite
simple zots or
pop rocks i know you don't need to look
them up
oh yeah one more thing the culture
corner rocks
double gang buzz squared
dude i want this guy to be an official
mascot
first of all kathy griffin fell off i'll
say that bro
but not surprising first of all i'm not
i'm not mad at carrot top's new gimmick
that [ __ ] is fire
he's pulling candy out of the trunk now
yeah dude shout out to that guy martin
and lewis from
who is that where is he from he didn't
say where he was from
that's the peace treaty guys or is it
martin lewis yeah i think that was the
old comedy oh super old school comedy
duo the original comedy duo
who founded america or found it that's
do you think of lewis and clark
yes shout out lewis and clark boy zots
were the
i'm not too familiar with zots they're
they're like the sour with they did like
the fizzy middle
no one knows huh yeah zots are a little
random now
so pop rocks all goddamn day i put them
in my mouth you like them oh i loved
them
pop rocks huh yeah but they were too
much of a dangerous candy for me i
remember
i remember had i had a couple i think i
had two of how many are in the package
there's a bunch in this one pack you can
dump a ball in your mouth and just
listen to
crackle pop oh yeah if you want to have
cte later in life
i wanted to live a regular existence so
i remember having one or two of the of
the rocks that's fair
and then choosing not to have any more
and i remember having a lot of liquor
made
look it made oh i know those zots remind
me of warheads
that's why i was trying to think of
about seven episodes ago ct my ass
warheads were dope
right uh you were wondering some for
seven episodes
or maybe that's a sign of ct but it did
just hit me bro yeah
warheads were the [ __ ] oh you guys know
what i'm talking about
chappelle no candy ever huh really why
what happened
god damn that candy it don't fit my
aggression
damn really what is it like what do you
mean about it like candy it's just too
sweet
yeah you know you don't have any sweet
teeth no even those front two you got
there
hey what's up man why you got to do that
no i'm just uh
yeah what the [ __ ] you you could say how
am i the bad guy you have great teams
you just literally don't want to make
anything about my skin tone but when you
talk about this game yeah
this is a different world michael
straight hand dude with the same oh
god one guy that's the oldest one in the
book worst joke i've ever heard about my
gap
right i love your gap i'm saved who
wouldn't want candy
so here's my thing bro i don't have
sweet i don't have a sweet tooth on
sweet tea
i love all all sugar do you you're not a
sugar guy
i'll have some i don't mind like a uh
maybe a creme brulee or something at
night
but you know or some uh a bread pudding
you know but nothing like a twizzler or
a red vine
or some runts i used to have runs when i
was young i remember from uh i think
sixth and seventh grade i would enjoy a
good box of runt yeah i feel like runts
would be your thing as a kid
i picked you with a backpack full of
ruts we used to play this game
sugar we put as much sugar you could in
your mouth and try to slap it out of
each other's mouths
sugar bugs because the moisture would
all absorb as much as it could and so
then you were real dried out and trying
to beat that sugar out of each other
damn called sugar sugar beet could be a
food game
sugar boys it was a game i'm telling you
it was a game it wasn't just a bunch of
stuff no i'm saying we could do it now
okay no you can you're trying to put
kool-aid in your mouth
the raw kool-aid the powder oh yeah bro
that's living brother your tongue would
be that color for the
rest of the month and what'd you guys
play back in the home country okay
the home country well she's from um
she's from america from
san jose
[Laughter]
um in my neighborhood you used to just
try to stay out of the way of cholas and
abg
oh there you go you run away from those
two and would you eat candy or
i mean what did everyone have shitty
childhoods besides me
if you hadn't if you had candy they
wanted to steal it from you so you had
to run off
if you win you keep your candy if not
you get your ass
you look like you're a kind of fast cat
fast enough
fast enough just very fast so so it was
a lot of uh there was a lot of gang
violence and stuff in the area
yes very ethnic gang violence wow it's
super culture in here today
is what you wanted
[Laughter]
what you lobbied for bro i wanted this
okay i thought i wanted this
so brandon you just can't tell you to
write your ideas out before you
you're right you're right i just set
everything up and then here we are
i think the show's gonna get canceled
well look dude or we're gonna get a
[ __ ] attack by
ms9 or whatever cat's old
neighbors are
[Laughter]
it was all fun and games just messing
around
dude it goes to show you what's going on
yeah you're right bro uh so debate
pop rocks but really warheads for me
well the man asked pop rocks or zots
dude this is a gentleman who spent time
to put that together and send that in
this
zotz man who is that what's the man's
name lonnie
ethan calhoun oh ethan calhoun brother
first of all yeah he does sound black
dude
and he might be black i didn't see the
mask how much of the i can't tell what
the mask what all
is that a riddler's mask he's wearing oh
his face looks kind of white a little
bit
i'm not mad at the bee though the little
buzz logo one
he'd be the president of the fan club if
he wants that's your that's your
henchman
the ethan calhoun fan club right there
does he say what city
he lives in not a lot of details huh
yeah probably
under around he's a bee yeah you're
right
um pop rocks though all right oh yeah 93
percent
with pop rocks because no one knows
what's hot no no zach you should have
done warheads with pop rocks well yeah
he should have done a candy from present
day
[Laughter]
you know he should have done a post 1985
[Music]
suite